[Music]
we are back and one of the great thrills
about hosting the Oscars for me is
moments like this here's a very special
woman a very special actress she is a
two-time Academy Award winner for Clute
and coming home so ladies and gentlemen
let's welcome home Jane Fonda the winner
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in 1954 a young polish artist and former
resistance fighter named NJ vada
directed his first feature film entitled
a generation it was followed by canal
and ashes and diamonds forming a
powerful trilogy which examined the
effects of war on his country's youth
this was the beginning of a remarkable
career in five decades and over 40 films
on Javita very intelligently and
sensitively explored the plight of human
beings caught in the chaos of history
it is my privilege to prevent present
this honorary Oscar to an Jay Veda
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen ben de mogi guaçu
box f / judge thomas ray emissions
observables Koh Samui atoms are set No
Nagaraja Kovu viruses nana metal column
near La Salette Gopal sky go kena
tomaten villainous egg fill move Marie
approaches tonnage is mo estranged take
a nice a communist
latigo taras shevchenko watch American
scheme Shri asharam Polsky
Amoy Radha come to him cry nazarov
ginger powe route dodging a democratic
snake Narada
dosa hog nativities Otzi Institute C
instructor Vespa transfer Carranza
partner ah be a denim exempt or ago -
Jacques Rogge Biogen VLK you chose me Oh
sh t
Ian snow ski a solid honesty
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]